vous imposez une facile alors je vais
vous ment permettre au petit retour sur
le niqab
d'abord le gouvernement fédéral demande
une suspension des procédures dans à peu
près toutes les causes
là vous êtes entré de l'accusé de
vouloir empêcher une seule femme de
voter est-ce que vous poussez un peu la
ligue loin et là dedans puis ma question
facile si on est à montréal max
pacioretty vient d'être choisi comme le
capitaine mes qualités parce que ça
alors d'abord je pense oui évidemment je
suis très content que que le canadien et
pâtures et et comme capitaine et j'ai
vraiment hâte que la saison commence cet
automne ça va a comme souvent pour les
canadiens deuxièmement on on voit
régulièrement à quel point un monsieur
un peu est toujours en train de miser
sur la peur et la division dans son
approche
c'est à ça que je trouve que il 6e à ce
niveau là que je trouve qu'ils se
trompent tellement il choisit toujours
de vouloir diviser les canadiens plutôt
que de rassembler il crée des peurs ils
soulignent des différences plutôt que de
démontrer qu'on est là pour défendre les
droits des minorités et cette société
extraordinaire forte pas en dépit de ces
différences mais à cause de ces
différences